uh
my name's uh uh noah hardwick
and um i'm from the university of
nottingham
um in the uk um and uh i work
uh part-time for uh and research and
have been doing so for
just over two years i think um and uh
over those two years um i've been
working on a new drawing tools project
um so we do have a set of drawing tools
in the product currently um but it's
quite old and it
needs to be sort of rewritten and
rethought um and so that's what this um
project is
um okay uh so
um just a brief sort of overview um of
what i'm gonna be talking about so
i sort of quickly want to cover the um
uh the motivation behind uh the project
um and uh how that sort of informed the
design principles and so i'll just talk
very
briefly about the the ux project because
it is
a project sort of principally about um
ux and design
um then uh i'll talk a bit about um
uh how you invoke uh the drawing tools
um which is with a new function
um called canvas um and then i'll get
into actually sort of you know using the
tools so i'll show you um formatting
annotation
um drawing from scratch and um finish
with uh then some sort of examples um
and uh what we are going to do in the
future with this
um so um yeah in terms of motivation um
the initial goal was simply just to
refactor
um the existing drawing tools uh into an
attached ribbon
and so if you in the product at the
moment control t
brings up the old drawing tools and as
you can see it's the sort of
old style inspector um and you sort of
you have to manually open and close
all the various um sections um
and of course uh when the image uh tools
came along they set a new precedence
um for how we do these sorts of tools
um and it's uh you know so they they
attach uh to an image
um and it's a more contextual things
obviously it's um it's based on the
selection and when you focus on the
selection that's when you get those
um tools uh and so um
yeah that's was sort of just the main
objective at first sort of you know put
all of this
into this um but uh
you know um this is obviously a very
good opportunity then to just sort of
reconsider the whole thing and
reconsider
um uh you know the sort of the structure
of the tools so we can do a bit more
than just sort of refactor them
um so uh and and the thing that sort of
drove
this was well we're sort of going in
this contextual direction because you
know they only appear when you select
the thing that you want to edit
um and so that sort of informs the
design principles and so i'll just
very as i said very briefly just talk
about the ux before i get into actually
demoing it
um so uh the sort of the main
principle that we were sort of working
by was um uh
you know we want to automate as much as
possible we want to make
it as contextual as possible so we only
want to show controls that are relevant
to the current selection
um you know that makes it easier to use
it it's visually less cluttered
um and so um
uh if i uh click all enable dynamics
i should have done that okay um and also
that's jumping around i'm just going to
quit
sorry one second
there we go okay um so uh
yes you invoke the drawing tools by
essentially wrapping a graphics object
in canvas but
as i said on the next slide i'll get on
to sort of canvas um in more detail
um but uh so these these work just like
the the image talks now so um
when you wrap the graphics in a canvas
and you have this canvas object
um it gives this sort of you know subtle
dotted line just to show you it's
something a bit different something
interactable
um and essentially what we've done is
we've taken all of the
um primitive insertion tools um so you
know for
actually drawing new elements into the
scene and made those into the ribbon
um and then author formatting tools um
are just
uh contained under the selection tab so
for example
i could you know i could go and click on
one of these and then start drawing
something
but actually um if i go ahead and just
select that disk
um we you know we thought it's fair to
assume that if you actually think you
know if you've selected the primitives
then you're
editing the scene so we can pop open the
controls automatically
and what you see here is that you have
these sort of little pods of controls
um and you only see the ones that are
relevant to the selection right so you
know this is a filled primitive so you
have you know fill and stroke and you
have a range obviously there's only one
primitive here so a range isn't that
useful
but you get the idea um we have this
saved styles at the top as well
um and that's sort of a little feature
within itself so i'll get on to that
later
but as you can see it's a way of you can
save
styles here and sort of organize them
and then
apply them to the selection but as i say
i'll get on to that
um excuse me uh right so
um okay so you know here's an example
with
uh two different types of primitive um
and so you know as you'd expect um if i
click on the arrow
um then i get the controls um personal
to arrows
and also you'll notice that it's not
just uh the different pods that appear
but the pods themselves are
some degree of contextual behavior as
well so for example fill and stroke has
now just changed such a stroke
but if i select the disc as well you
know we're taking the union
of those two um of all of those sets of
controls
excuse me um and so you know now we get
for example you know fill and stroke and
stroke is going to change the edge of
the disc
and also the uh the the line of the
arrow
um so yes okay so
now i will get on to canvas so currently
um the drawing tools uh only attach to
canvas objects
um and that is because um the drawing
tools and canvas itself are experimental
experimental features at the moment the
idea with this project
is that eventually the drawing tools you
know much like the image tools attached
to any image
the drawing tools will attach to any
relevant graphics so you know
outputs of plot and things like that um
but uh yeah they're experimental at the
moment so you have to sort of manually
invoke them by wrapping the thing in
canvas
um that being said canvas itself has
some useful features
um and so even when you know we uh
start attaching it to everything we will
still keep canvas
um and uh yeah there's so there are
three ways of interacting with canvas
um one uh is for editing graphics
themselves so
in this case uh the entire graphic is
selectable
and all the primitives in it are
editable like the examples i just showed
above
you know i could i could actually go and
select those individual primitives and
change them
um and you get that by just simply
wrapping the graphic in canvas
um then there's the second behavior
which is for annotating graphics
and here the graphic is not uh
selectable
uh nor editable um and it is just used
as a background so it's not
you can't it's sort of protected um you
can it doesn't have to be a graphic you
can't actually put anything as the
backgrounds and then you can draw over
it which is quite neat
i'll i'll show you examples of that
later um
and then the third thing uh canvas you
can just um specify it with no arguments
in which case you get a
a blank canvas um uh in which you are
free to just draw from scratch
um and actually that tends to that can
be quite useful
um for we we uh introduced some spline
tools um into uh into the drawing tools
and so if any of you um
have used graphics packages like
illustrator or photoshop
and it's essentially the pen tool from
them um from those
and uh it means that you can draw
splines and
well from language in a blank canvas
then you can easily just get that out
and use it in you know animation or
graphic or whatever
um and again i'll show an example of
that
so let's start with formatting existing
graphics um so let's you know just
this is a relatively straightforward
example um
and uh you know i'm just going to
make that a bit bigger uh image size
let's say 500 whoops
sorry uh plots there we go
um right so um yeah in terms of actually
like formatting what's in a graphic
um you know i i you know i've sort of
plotted out
um various standing modes uh uh
on a string for example of vibration um
and
uh let's say i just want to sort of draw
attention to one of them well you know
um
it's relatively simple uh you know i can
just select all the ones
um that i don't want to see and uh you
know we can just make those
um gray this is obviously very a very
simple example just to show you how this
is working
um and then the one that we do see um
it's actually behind some of the others
um so let's you know let's bring it to
the front um and then we can increase
the thickness on it as well
um and there we go so that's just a very
simple example
of editing of formatting what's already
genographic
um so here's something interesting um
because of course you could you don't
have to use the sort of you know
the background option um for annotation
you i could of course just start
you know putting arrows and text and
circling things in this
um and so i'm trying to think of a good
example of when you'd want to do that
um and actually one did spring to mind
and so a while ago i was giving
a presentation um and uh this code is
not really important what's important is
the output
um and uh basically it was uh you've got
um a lattice of ions here
and i'm just giving some indication of
how an electron wave function
um fits in that lattice just you know
very rough
um but what i had to do when i did this
uh was
sort of you know um put a frame around
this uh and then sort of manually try
and work out
you know okay what are the plot points i
want for my path and actually i had to
write them all out manually
um so obviously that was you know
frustrating and a pain well now um if i
comment that bit out
um i can do that with the swine tool
which is quite neat
um so uh i will go into um polyline
uh and um we've got these uh nice
controls here for uh for for drawing
splines there's actually bezier curves
um and so uh again as i say if you you
know if you're if you're
um familiar with illustrator and
packages like that then then this this
will be nothing new
um but uh i'm able to i'm able to um
click uh and uh
drag to change the curvature and as you
can see there and we have you know
um controls okay i do not know why
that's happening
you can see why this is experimental um
should we try that once more before we
give up ah there we go perfect um and so
you know you click to place the point
and then you drag to to move it around
and i won't do any more than that
um and then you can you know you're able
to move the nodes as well
um and then go back and uh change the
curvature so these we can
you know we haven't had these tools in
wolfram language before um but we have
quite nice graphics capabilities
um and so it's quite nice that the week
that we have this now
um so um yeah uh
i will commit that there we go um
not a very good wave function uh okay so
let's look at
annotation now um so let's just go for a
super simple example
um and again actually i'm just going to
stick an image size option here to make
it bigger
we go um and so um
you know again this is just a very
simple example and so you know we've got
these two tools here
um which are sort of you know just for
circling things
um and drawing boxes around things so uh
i i suppose i should say you know when
you click on a primitive insertion tab
you then get the controls
button to it underneath um and so you
know i can
i can circle that uh intersection with
the axis there
and if i go and format it um
you know let's make it uh let's make it
red um and let's make it
um a bit thicker and uh then
i can also draw an arrow as well and um
the arrow the poly arrow tool is
actually a bezier arrow which is quite
cool
um so i can draw um
and remember i can draw just sort of
like an angled one without clicking and
dragging i can just click to place the
points
um and so there we go we have a nice um
arrow there and uh i commit that
and now um we also have quite nice
uh controls for um uh editing arrows
and so we we have this arrow slider here
in fact let's make this black
so it's a bit bit clearer um we have
uh sorry one second
um so guess it's black uh and this is
actually a slider and so i can change
the position of the arrowhead along the
shaft
um and uh i can you know i can i can
choose
uh you know i can i can choose custom
heads here
um and i can add heads as well um
uh let's have that scaled because
there's a bug at the moment there we go
um and so
it's just quite a neat way of uh you
know building up some you know very
custom arrows and also got presets as
well
so there we go there's and obviously if
i was so inclined i could add text you
know saying
intersection points um but um i can do
that now
um so okay this is sort of the first
actually kind of interesting bit
um which is uh you can extract the
annotation so
let's say you've got a plot that's
non-trivial and so
um here's one that i made earlier um
this was for uh
a report um i should say that i studied
physics by the way so that's why all
these examples
um are sort of physics related um and so
these are emission spectra for black
bodies um various different temperatures
and they're they're planky curves
um and so this is my plot um
and uh let's just get rid of that we
don't need to see it um and so i'm going
to use the background option here
um and so you can start with the dotted
line i've got this canvas
um and so let's uh let's add um an
annotation here
um so uh let's add an annotation
um and let's add some uh text
and i'm going to say that uh
f uh if i want to say that f
max is equal to some constant times
uh temperature um and uh
then i'm going to make this a bit bigger
um with our text tools um
uh there we go okay and you know what
let's make that arrow black
um now what if you want to change the
plot underneath now obviously
you know if it's something like just
changing the thickness of one of the
lines yeah you can go ahead and do that
with the drawing tools you wouldn't
you'd have to use it
not with the background option but you
could do that but let's say i'm not
happy with
four thousand five thousand six thousand
seven thousand kelvin i actually want to
change it
um and so i'm going to uh
sorry and so so the input form of what
i've drawn is a canvas object
and then the first argument of that is
the graphic that i just drew
and then the second argument is the
background so if i say
annotation equals first
of this i get the annotation out um and
i've assigned that to annotation so
now uh i'm going to update the plot
um and then i'm going to display canvas
of annotation
and the background goes to this new plot
and so there look see we've
um we've updated the the plot um
so we've got a different uh set of plant
curves there and the annotation has uh
persisted
because we were able to save it um
so okay blank canvas uh drawing from
scratch
um so i am running a bit behind so i'll
do this bit
very quickly um uh
let's um i think okay the best thing to
show here is probably the shapes
tab and we have quite a nice shapes tab
i mean in the future we want to sort of
flesh this out a bit
um but we've been able to sort of uh
write a tool that will insert any
arbitrary
uh primitive into the graphic and so
let's uh you know let's insert
this uh disk here and now what we've
actually inserted
is uh not a disk but a bezier curve um
and so uh you know we can go ahead and
edit this
um and uh uh
yeah and so i i think um you know this
this would be useful for when you want
to sort of make some kind of
um graphic uh to use in perhaps an
animation or perhaps an education visual
visualization where you want something
to look nice um i was actually doing the
coursework
uh last week um where i had to uh
simulate
uh rocket trajectories and um i used
this uh
just a blank canvas to draw a little
rocket icon and then dug it out and
stuck it into the
um uh into the simulation and so it's
quite nice to be able to do that
completely within
uh mathematica now um or from language i
should say
um and i think the last thing i'll show
for this is um the styles paint so i'd
come back to this
so we've got quite a nice way to um save
and organize and apply
um styles um so these are the four
default ones that we supply and then
i've saved a few of my own over here
and then i could i can add more and so
basically um
you know let's say uh i want to apply
this style and so that's made it um
you know sort of a about 50 opacity i
think and added a solid line to the end
um but actually let's see i'm not quite
happy with that i want that line to be a
bit thicker
and let's make it an absolute thickness
um
i can then i can redefine the cell so i
can update it
and obviously there wasn't any text
there so it's got rid of the text um
and then yeah i can sort of organize
these uh move them around um you know i
can add them from scratch if i want
um and uh yeah and delete them as well
by the way you can
you can get rid of them and if you
notice those first three ones there
um match the you know the default colors
in plot um
so yes oh and yeah okay
okay so here we go here's a slightly
more sort of involved uh
example um so uh
the you i said at the beginning
but the option to um the background
option into canvas doesn't have to be
just the 2d graphics so
this was um something i was doing for um
a project with
uh magnetic residence imaging and so
what i've got here
is um uh you know this this bit had to
be zoned programmatically right and so
you know these are um these are dipoles
in your sample and usually obviously
they'd be aligned with the
earth's field so they'll be pointing
upright and what we've done here is just
kick them out of alignment
and if i play this um you can see that
they process back around
um and then uh you can pick up that
radiation that they're giving off
and the idea is if i change the field
over this
excuse me you can see that the rate of
procession has now changed
and incidentally that's how you encode
spatial information um
in an mri image that's that's that's how
you do it
so okay um what i would quite like to do
with this
is um obviously you know we've got this
uh we've got this field
and and so what there really is is a
coil going around it to generate that
field
um and uh i could have that
programmatically but it's a pain you
have to you know style everything and
then
you know nudge it a bit to the left
nudge it a bit to the right so i just
want to be able to draw on this
um so what i'm going to do i've wrapped
this
here uh i've just put a canvas
background goes to
this drawing and so what i'm going to do
is let me
is insert um a
rectangle and now obviously this is not
just a rectangle this is
a bezier curve as well um and so
i can move these points and so let's
move it into the place where
sort of you know the call will be on the
side i just all i want to do here is
give some
indication on this diagram that there is
a coil that's
that's going round this okay um so i'm
going to get it roughly
roughly in position there um and then
i'm going to
use the curvature tool here um
to uh uh to curve this so it's looking
sort of like
at the edge of a coil um and i'm gonna
do the same
that's the wrong control point i'm going
to do the same here as well
there we go um and uh yeah i'm happy
with that let's draw that in
um and then let's format it as well so
let's make it
um you know let's let's make the fill so
it looks a bit like copper
let's have an orange fill and then let's
put the stroke as a darker orange
um and a little bit of thickness there
uh telephone head on screen
okay perfect right so
what i can now do with this um is if i
just deselect this and then select
the canvas i'm going to copy this so i'm
going to command c on the keyboard
and then when i paste it out if the
background is not a 2d graphic
um it just gives you the annotation that
you've done and so there's my annotation
and so now i can assign this to
annotation
there we go um and uh
i can then say canvas
hey that was not what i wanted to do
and adaptation that's spelled correctly
and rotation there we go and evaluate
this
and now um obviously you know
i've just done this very roughly and
obviously you could draw whatever you
wanted in
in in here is often used to useful be
able to sort to 2d elements over things
um but now you know if i play this this
is now within that animation so that's
kind of useful
um now uh a slightly more uh involved
example or something a useful example
perhaps of this again
um is uh i'm going to delete those
because they may well slow things down
there we go um is this example um and so
this
this will take uh you know a couple
minutes so i don't have time to do it
here but i just want to show you
that then this is sort of like a you
know like a real life application i
suppose of this kind of
use of canvas and background um and so
because i said the background could be
anything you know what i constructed
programmatically
was this animation and this graph
um and then the bits that i uh drew in
manually which would have been a
nightmare to kind of you know do with
offset and then try and put the numbers
in and then evaluate it and nudge a bit
and evaluate
um uh is uh i just
you know you use the create canvas sorry
use a canvas and uh drew
um you know drew these 2d elements here
so uh the
the you know the detection coil and
added this text and added this line
um and also uh this wave which then i
sort of pulled out
put a parameter and stuck back in um
so i think that's quite a nice example
of how this is sort of you know
genuinely quite useful for
for these animations that you can make
um
and i'm running out of time uh but that
is okay because i'm roughly
at the end so um future work um
obviously as i've already said we want
to attach this to all uh you know
relevant graphics
um it wouldn't make sense to put us on a
graph uh but it would make sense
on the outputs of plots and things like
that um we
would like um uh oh sorry and obviously
part of that
is uh you know this is an experimental
feature and
uh so we need to sort of you know do
some work getting a bit more stable
um uh you know robustifying it a bit um
but what's useful about this project is
that it's being deployed as a packet so
we will be able to update it in the
field
um we want a richer interface for the uh
style picker because that is quite a
useful feature being able to save styles
obviously they persist over sessions
um and so being able to you know perhaps
it sort of expand a bit and
uh uh you know a bit uh easier to
to organize um and then i think the sort
of no-brainer as well as a library of
shapes as i said you know um
there's no reason why we can't have you
know basic shapes flowchart elements
circuit diagram elements
anything really um as soon as we have
the capability to just insert any
primitive that we want um
so yes and so i'd like to finish on this
is the drawing tools team
um obviously me as well um so yeah uh
you know those thanks to these guys uh
john uh and lou
um for all the help on the front end
stuff um powerful project managing
and uh brett um has really steered and
guided this project
over the last two years so uh thanks
thanks guys
um i think that is uh yeah that is me
done with two minutes to spare so
um i will see if we've got any questions
and we
do
uh
i can't see any questions um so
if uh there were some refresher page you
know ah thank you
just refreshing
oh right okay yeah there's loads okay uh
let's see let's do this in order
uh this feature will be in 12 2. um as
experimental
um and as i say just invoked with create
canvas
um i can't see anything
uh thank you uh well the newly added
uh yes uh it
needs so i'm answering this question
about um the tech input feature
it does work um but i think uh
uh the last time i looked at it it just
needed a bit more attention but it
should work and we should have
time to do that hopefully before 12-2
ships
um are the safe styles yes they are oh
uh they are not shareable
um but we could make them shareable but
they are
uh they are global in the sense that
they persist
you know across sessions across
notebooks um you know
close mathematically down open it up
again you'll still have them uh yes
they'll be in twelve two
what about yes uh that's a very good
question about touch screens um which we
uh haven't uh done yet um
but uh uh yeah we have
we have um a freehand tool as well um
that brett's answered that thank you
do the textual support subscripting
that'll be useful yes they do
um in fact there are two text tools um
there are uh
uh we've got normal text and we've got
math text as well which
um you know formats automatically as as
a piece of math
um 300 reasons yes
i agree uh oh yes you can
uh you can't that's a global option that
we should really put in the drawing
tools
um i think
zoom is hiding my toolbar at the top
here um but uh oh
there we go it is in one of these menus
um snapping is in one of these menus
uh a light there we go alignment guides
enabled you can do that
um manipulates two yes anything
anything can be the background um uh
obviously if you're going to link it to
that you'd have to sort of draw the
thing in your canvas and then
sort of manually put it in the
manipulate unless you were literally
just wanting to draw over it as i showed
with that animate
um interest that's good thank you
uh great thank you um is apostles raw on
top of the whole notebook
no uh because you'd have to attach a
cell over the whole thing so
uh no you wouldn't be able to
um and
that is that is time up and i think that
is all the questions so
thanks um everyone for listening i i
hope you enjoyed the presentation
and um yeah thanks
you